the video game industry is constantly
growing and generating billions upon
billions of dollars as such major
publishers are always looking at which
games are selling well with an intention
to repeat that success over and over
these kinds of blockbuster games tend to
be the ones that post cutting-edge
graphics be heavy on action and aren't
overly challenging while this isn't
necessarily a bad formula there's
something to be said for the developers
who make games that don't follow these
current trends and instead incorporate
all the mechanics which some may
consider to be dated these are the games
that remind us and play like the titles
you fell in love with in the first place
the game that's been absorbing all of my
personal hours at the moment is divinity
original sin and it's a really good
example of what's so great about this
old-school revival trend original sin
was kick-started for almost a million
bucks and is currently one of the most
talked about rpgs on the Internet as
well as being the best-selling one on
Steam the difference between this and
other popular role-playing games like
Skyrim is that divinity plays like an
old-school computer RPG from 1999 this
means it's hardcore extremely
challenging and easy to make mistakes
that can pretty quickly halt your
progress the amount to which you'll find
yourself struggling in the game is
related much less to which difficulty
you choose and much more to the
decisions you make about your play style
since the game demands some serious
tactical prowess in its combat and
puzzling scenarios a fight can easily be
won or lost by one clever or poor choice
those who think carefully about
optimizing their characters properly
balancing magic users and rogues with
frontline fighters for example will have
a much better chance at coming out alive
oh why is challenging a good thing
because gamers aren't stupid major
publishers aren't usually very keen on
releasing punishing games Skyrim has a
very gradual difficulty curve and the
game scales to your character for
example but the popularity of original
sin Dark Souls and retro platformer is
like shovel Knight
so just that players are happy to have a
challenge so long as that challenge is
fair and can ultimately be overcome with
enough thought skill and practice not
every game needs to be dumbed down some
people think that since games have
evolved so much these older mechanics
should be updated but personally I think
there's so much value in keeping them
around divinity looks gorgeous and feels
modern without letting go of old school
mechanics like turn-based combat
turn-based gameplay was born out of pen
and paper RPGs we're a game master
couldn't very well take on every
player's request to Stabbin zap any
given beasty all at the same time
turn-taking also lent itself to party
driven computer RPGs like might and
magic here you could single-handedly
control a bunch of really different
characters with their own races and
classes executing widely different
attacks or spells at maximum efficiency
these days games are at the point where
they can let the console or computer
process all the player requests at the
same time I have AI help you out with
your party combat like in Bioware's
Dragon Age king's bounty the legend a
reworking of the 1990 strategy game
bearing the same name largely retains
the mechanics its series was built upon
even though they could be considered
dated it's managed to modernize without
completely submitting to the trends of
modern games it's graphically impressive
and has updated certain mechanics like
opting for more flexible exploration but
the dev still understand that a lot of
people continue to appreciate features
like resource management and turn-based
combat fun in the same vein shovel
Knight was created within the graphical
constraints of an 8-bit Nintendo game
and offers old-school challenging
platforming but it implements a
relatively modern checkpoint system
unlike the games that inspired it which
didn't save your progress at all this is
a great and sensible balance of
old-school and new-school given there's
nothing all that sexy about resource
management and slow punishing gameplay
the issue with them that game set on
retaining old-school graphics and
features generally aren't
thought to get big publishers on board
that's the most important thing about
these games that refused to conform to a
streamlined and accessible blockbuster
formula is that they're proving players
are really interested in having these
niche experiences there's a good chance
we'll always have big-budget action
games first-person shooters and hack and
slash Diablo clones but smaller genres
rely on independent publishing and
consumer support Kickstarter has let
gamers have a huge say in what they want
to play and people can vote with their
wallets now more than ever developers
who don't want to compromise on the
old-school inspired experiences they're
offering need an alternative to the
support of big publishers luckily if
things trend the way they are with the
success of divinity original sin shovel
knight and king's bounty it seems that
alternative is fully viable and will
have room to thrive be sure to head to
that comment section and let me know
which modern nostalgia inspired games
are your favorite and which all the
games you don't want to see disappear I
will see you soon